[Música]
[Aplausos]
Bienvenidos a corresponsales el programa
de France 24 que los invita a dar una
vuelta al mundo de la mano de nuestra
red de periodistas comenzamos Este
programa en Estados Unidos un país
conmocionado por la muerte de tyricles
una afroamericano de 29 años en un nuevo
acto de violencia policial el
departamento de policía de la ciudad de
Memphis publicó el video de la brutal
paliza que le propinaron cinco agentes
estas personas ya han sido retiradas de
sus cargos y ahora enfrentan cargos por
asesinato en segundo grado en las calles
de Memphis las personas han seguido
manifestando exigiendo reformas
profundas a nivel nacional informe de
basimme y macho y
el dolor y la conmoción se convirtieron
en rabia y determinaciones de sábado
cuando un centenar de manifestantes
desafió la fría lluvia y se tomó las
calles de Memphis su objetivo honrar y
recordar a tyrey Nichols de 29 años y
padre de un niño además de exigir
cambios drásticos en el sistema policial
del país un sistema que estos
manifestantes dicen no hace nada para
prevenir el uso de la violencia
básicamente lo que hay que hacer es
mejorar la policía necesitamos algún
tipo de entrenamiento un entrenamiento
mental para los agentes Porque algunos
de ellos están básicamente locos y les
gusta matar
desde la muerte de tyrey Nichols gran
parte de la indignación se ha centrado
en el uso excesivo de la fuerza policial
durante incidentes que son menores según
los agentes Nichols fue arrestado por
conducir rápido una detención violenta
que era totalmente innecesaria
manifestantes creo que la gente no
necesita ser detenida por delitos no
violentos y la violencia no Debería ser
la primera respuesta a cualquier tipo de
conexión con agentes de la ley o
cualquier otra persona con autoridad sí
creo que todo el sistema necesita
cambiar
la policía es un sistema de supremacía
blanca y creo que también es importante
mencionar que no fueron solo cinco
policías negros sino que un policía
blanco utiliza un teaser contra Nicole y
luego les dijo a los demás que le dieran
una paliza antes de alejarse y luego de
sus cinco policías lo persiguieron y lo
asesinaron y ese sistema es el que causó
la muerte de Nicole a mitad de la marcha
a los manifestantes recibieron una buena
noticia la disolución de la unidad
escorpio el grupo de los cinco hombres
responsables de la brutal paliza un gran
cambio de tono Solo un día después de
que el jefe de policía dijera que a
pesar de la muerte de Nichols la fuerza
especial había hecho más bien que mal
la batalla en el este de Ucrania se
recrudecen particularmente en la
provincia de daniesk alrededor de la
localidad de bakmuth donde las tropas
rusas siguen ganando territorio los
aliados de kiev han anunciado el envío
de tanques modernos como los leopardos
alemanes o los abrams estadounidenses
sin embargo se han rehusado a aceptar
las nuevas peticiones de Ucrania que
ahora Busca acceder a aviones de casa
nuestra enviada especial a Ucrania
Catalina Gómez Ángel registró las
extremas dificultades de los habitantes
de Batman solo los vehículos de los
militares y de los voluntarios transitan
por backmud que desde hace meses es el
gran objetivo las fuerzas de Moscú
Dimitri deje la situación local de los
servicios de emergencia de Ucrania hoy
reubicados en una localidad cercana esta
mañana han venido hasta backmuk
respondiendo al llamado de un hombre
mayor enfermo de cáncer que ha pedido
ser evacuado de la ciudad
todo lo que podamos hacer de nuestro
lado lo hacemos pero todo el mundo tiene
una opinión propia sobre lo que hay que
hacer en estos momentos nosotros no
estamos en condiciones de decirles Cómo
actuar
al menos 5000 personas de los 60.000 que
habitaban en la ciudad se han negado a
partir se han quedado a pesar de la
destrucción y de que la batalla cada vez
está cerca
fuimos atacados de nuevo por eso tenemos
que vivir en el sótano porque las piezas
de los cohetes y proyectiles vuelan
alrededor
pero como muchos vladimirencia dice que
se queda porque no tiene dinero y jugar
a donde ir y es que aquí cada uno parece
tener sus propias convicciones para
quedarse
no le deseo a nadie que experimente algo
como esto yo tengo 86 años usted me
acomodaría a esta edad en su casa no en
mi calle soy el único que no se ha ido
todas las casas Están o destruidas o
dañadas
las autoridades con la ayuda de los
voluntarios llevan realizando
evacuaciones durante meses muchos
deciden irse Solo cuando su casa es
alcanzada por un proyectil Entonces si
toman la decisión la mayoría son
personas mayores que vivieron Durante
los tiempos de la unión soviética su
supervivencia depende de centros como
estos a los que llegan arriesgando sus
vidas aquí buscan el abrigo la luz el
agua y el alimento que no tienen en sus
casas este lugar es importante para
nosotros no tenemos agua electricidad en
la casa vivimos gracias a estos centros
Dimitri pasa los días en este otro
centro ubicado en un sótano en uno de
los sectores más atacados por las
fuerzas rusas dice que se han quedado
para acompañar a su abuela mi vida
empieza con la idea de encontrar la
manera segura de llegar hasta aquí
rápido y luego en la tarde tenemos que
pensar en cómo regresar al apartamento
su sueño como el del resto es que se
silencia en Los cañones que apuntan
sobre backmud en el tercer aniversario
de la salida del Reino Unido de la Unión
Europea el fondo monetario internacional
publicó sus previsiones para la economía
británica esta se contraería en un 0,6%
en 2023 convirtiéndola en la única
Economía del g7 que no registraría el
crecimiento este año los ciudadanos
británicos siguen a la espera de los
dividendos de aquellas grandes promesas
que hizo el Gobierno en 2020 porque
desde que se concretó el brexit el país
ha estado sometido a la inestabilidad
política a la escasez de trabajadores
para labores poco calificadas y a una
burocracia mucho más complicada a la
hora de querer exportar sus productos
hacia el bloque europeo lo que ha dejado
en grandes dificultades A muchas
empresas locales como nos cuentan Luisa
Pulido y Anita montaldo
Alejandro Uribe es importador de flores
colombianas ecuatorianas en el Reino
Unido desde hace 25 años pero los
últimos tres años con la llegada del
brexit su negocio se ha visto afectado
por los trámites de nacionalización solo
Los costos se le han incrementado en un
20%
son similares los requisitos pero se han
duplicado antes uno importaba y
nacionalizaba una sola vez hoy en día
nos toca hacerlo dos veces porque son
dos mercados son dos autoridades
fitosanitarias para los productos que
ves son dos aduanas a pocos días de la
celebración de San Valentín le preocupan
las ventas porque debe incluir el mismo
porcentaje de los gastos en los precios
de las flores provenientes de Suramérica
ha incertidumbre Aquí van a haber
huelgas la gente está haciendo muchas
huelgas hay huelgas de transporte tiene
que haber buenas ventas opino yo pero no
va a ser fácil y los las preventas han
sido menores porque la gente está
es dueño de esta fabricante de bandejas
de aluminio una marca tradicional hace
76 años en Londres cuyo 40% de
producción se vende en Europa luego de
tres años solo ha visto complicaciones
en el negocio
antes del brexit era súper simple era
como enviar algo al siguiente pueblo de
Inglaterra nada que hacer ningún
procedimiento entonces mientras que
antes tomaba uno o dos días enviar algo
digamos a París o Berlín o donde sea
ahora puede tomarse semanas y en algunos
casos puede tomar meses
al estar el Reino Unido fuera del
mercado único y las aduanas europeas
exportar se ha vuelto una dificultad
para esta empresa familiar
en teoría enviará otros países europeos
ahora es lo mismo que enviar al resto
del mundo que también hacemos mucho
Parece más fácil llevar las cosas a
Francia que a los Estados Unidos
los empresarios británicos le han pedido
a su gobierno un nuevo acuerdo para
reducir la burocracia en las
exportaciones para poder equilibrar las
pérdidas que les ha dejado la separación
del bloque europeo
Brasil es el segundo país del mundo con
más casos de lepra después de India
conocida en el mundo médico como la
enfermedad de hansen esta es una de las
afecciones más antiguas ya existían
registros de ella en el siglo sexto
antes de Cristo y entre 2016 y 2020
Brasil registró más de 155 mil nuevos
casos a pesar de que las cifras cayeron
en las estadísticas durante la pandemia
de covid-19 no cayó su incidencia real y
hoy por hoy la lepra es considerada una
enfermedad endémica en este país
Tropical nos lo cuentan Valeria sacone y
amín guidal
hace siete meses este hombre de 51 años
descubrió que padece una enfermedad que
todavía genera discriminación
yo estaba en casa y cuando me levanté mi
cuerpo estaba lleno de pequeñas manchas
no sabía lo que era fui al médico y
pensó que era viruela del mono
sin embargo el diagnóstico fue
inesperado enfermedad de hansen
popularmente conocida como lepra yo no
tuve miedo el problema principal es
contárselo a las personas no todo el
mundo sabe lo que es la enfermedad de
hansen hay mucho prejuicio Hoy es un día
importante porque Fernando va a empezar
su tratamiento en la fundación Osvaldo
cruz de Río de Janeiro es todo más
referencia en la investigación
científica en Brasil
cuando empieza a tomar el remedio la
única cosa que le pasa a todo el mundo
es que su orina se va a quedar muy roja
a pesar de ser el segundo país del mundo
con más casos según la Organización
Mundial de la Salud todavía hay mucha
desinformación
lo que importa para la enfermedad de
hansen es hacer un diagnóstico precoz y
un tratamiento precoz sólo así vamos a
poder evitar la incapacidad la
deformidad y el estigma la enfermedad de
hansen no es tan contagiosa como se
piensa se contrae por las vías
respiratorias pero solo tras una
convivencia prolongada con algún enfermo
no va a haber problemas porque sabemos
que esta enfermedad tiene tratamiento
vas a quedar bien solo tienes que
medicarte correctamente Fernando no va a
tener que pagar nada por la atención
médica ni por los medicamentos el
sistema Público de salud cubre todos los
gastos
es un año de tratamiento y se cura al
100% Durante un año una vez por mes
vendré aquí para hacer las revisiones
para ver cómo estoy
la Organización Mundial de la Salud
espere erradicar esta enfermedad en 2030
hasta Entonces Fernando Espera que para
él sea tan solo un recuerdo
Muchas gracias por seguir un nuevo
episodio de corresponsales nos damos
cita la próxima semana siga como esa
información en France 24 y France 24.com
[Aplausos]